hello i am nyan chanda editor of Elle
global online and we are delighted
our Studios boo Eggman Bookman is the
founder and executive chairman of
Torborg foundation will welcome thank
you so you have spent a normal amount of
time studying this climate issue and
they planetary health now we are facing
in North America at least an Arctic
winter so people are asking is the
global warming story for real what if
say well we share your your arctic cold
also in in my neck of the woods and
Sweden and in Northern Europe and I I'm
afraid it's for real and this is this is
part of the consequences of global
warming how do you explain global
warming causing arctic cold I it seems
to be a paradox but but my scientist
friends tell me it is it's it is not and
they explained it this way the the
Arctic if you use this as a as a model
of the North Pole area the the Arctic
area the air pressure has over time
being very stable and around the pole
that has been sort of a sense of between
the cold air and the warmer air a damn
further to the south now this femmes
have been weakened and tons of very cold
arctic air are seeping down towards
Europe and towards this is energy in the
form of jet stream yes exactly this this
fence is actually part of the circle jet
stream now
the thing is that up here on the cap the
global warming is at its apex in the
world and I have personally travel to to
the Arctic in for many years to study
the advancement of global warming of
what it does to the land ice of the sea
ice and to the people who live up there
and and combining my the witness of my
eyes and the experience of the people
who live there and and the scientific
evidence makes me convinced that this is
for real also the long-term our
projection through complex mathematical
models has for decades told us basically
this is the store is going to happen and
just north of Greenland if the
temperature has risen with with four
degrees average and the place I go to in
and Greenland's called alula shot
beautiful place and there's one of the
more mighty glaciers are emptying is his
eyes in and in the Atlantic arm there
when I started to travel there the eyes
moved the speed of of 18 meters a day
and ten years later it was 38 38 meters
a day and now it's up to over 45 me so
almost so the word glacial speed has to
be devised because the Essex it is
sprinting rather than is becoming
Godspeed yes so but apart from what you
observed yourself in terms of global
warming accelerating the melting of ice
what are these scientific evidence
globally that you have to indicate that
there is indeed a global warming well
are the density of co2 in the atmosphere
but started to be measured in the 50s by
by an American keeling I don't know
Hawaii and this density of co2 actually
indicates global at the greenhouse gas
yes which keeps caps the the temperature
heat doesn't cannot get out of their
atmosphere the stairs with him it caps
the solar energy yeah it doesn't diva
and also the shrinking of the ice aside
that the shrinking of the ice the sea
ice the Arctic sea ice has been
staggering since 79 when we first
started to measure with help of us
satellites the the width and the depth
of the ice it shrank with more than
thirty percent thirty five percent so
going back to the co2 you are saying
that he started measuring that indeed
and in the 50s yes yeah and and we now
know that co2 oscillated between 190 ppm
which is parts per million and 280 in a
million a sort of molecule of affair yes
300 how much was it and 100 when when it
was where we have this stable situation
of the last 10,000 12,000 years it was
isolated between 119 280 at the top now
it is at at 390 which is very alarming
and it's pushing up and and so what it
means is that 390 ppm of co2 in the air
increase tremendously possibility of
that most fear we keep renewing armor
and warmer yes yes exactly that's the
result n 0 co co 2 are the emissions
from from for example fossil fuels by
combustion of fossil fuels is is is one
of the biggest but is the biggest but
there were also other sources of
greenhouse
gases like maintain and we are on our
way towards 450 if not 500 and and the
science test like Jim Hansen at NASA and
columbia university has together with
with a with a number of scientists
convincingly told us that that the icing
of the polls only starts at a density of
co2 of 450 plus or minus a hundred so if
we want to be on the safe side it's my
conviction reading and and seeing all
this is that we should we should
backtrack to 350 at least so a 450 if it
reaches for 150 the chance that the
polar ice would start melting yes and
once start melting there is no going
back no it's irreversible but but of
course we can wear new energy
technologies and with new consumption
patterns and new living passenger we can
stall the emissions and we can possibly
backtrack I am an optimist there so
sorry exactly what does it ask that it
is now 3 90 yeah and the target that we
want to bring it down to 350 yes how
does one dish that goal what are these
well it's a mixture of policies I think
one of the most important policies to is
to have a global carbon tax that that
you put a price on emissions that will
force the market to develop new
technologies that have the capacity to
to you know decrease
my come to Sweden installed his first
tax from carbon in 1990 and and today we
have we are well on our way to become
carbon neutral it's been a rapid and
very successful development and our
which means the core carbon neutral it
means that you are not emitting any more
co2 exactly exactly the US mhm 20 tonne
per person and a sweets amid today less
than six tonnes per person Wow and our
standard of living is yeah as good as
yours yeah so so the carbon tax is one
and what are the other other things one
can do are well it's across new tech
energy technologies clean energy
technology and and the most helpful is
cause solar technology with I willna
never go out of of that source will not
stop for another building for other
billion of years and I'm very hopeful
that it's mega investments done by China
also here and in Europe and a lot of
good brains at work so i think the
efficiency of solar energy will will
increase exponentially and the costs
will go down I'm also hopeful of a third
and a fourth generation of nuclear
nuclear power and of course also more
efficient combustion engines and they
are already now hitting the market but
the learning curves are are very fast we
knew need better insulation we need
lighter materials and and whatnot and
and you also can see that parts of of
the non matter based on on a team based
economy is growing very fast digital
economy yeah
which which doesn't use atoms much no
not use brains yes now the point this is
that as we have seen in Copenhagen that
the country is gathering there simply
could not agree on how to go about
capping the mission now what you are
suggesting ultimately requires countries
to cede bit of their sovereignty for the
common good now is that possible has it
happened before that people have
actually given up a little bit of the
sovereignty in order to have achieved a
common objective yes it happens happens
all the time and happens today the the
basic reason for for moving in that
direction that is I don't mean to do
away with nation-states we need them for
for our culture identity for for our
political processes and building our
communities and so forth is that we have
become so deeply interdependent in in
certain aspects of life like energy
production like the panels on ecosystem
services like order forest land
fisheries and so forth and of course the
climate can't be fixed by any one single
nation that has to be fixed in consort
between all nations and now I think the
I think that's in your question that the
present design of negotiations are not
is not conducive to them conducive to
sold to solve the problem the
negotiations like the Copenhagen
negotiations are we because the Kyoto
Protocol process
is designed to still maximize each
nations and Trust and at these meetings
I've been them watching them and study
them every delegation represents its
nation's interest so one little part of
the planet you represent exactly yeah or
a big party plan together like China
United States and so forth the two
biggest emitters and and of course they
linked the curbing of emissions and the
acceptance of new levies proof somber
taxes as a threat to economic growth to
prosperity to profits and to also to
security in military strength so this
this is a very very complex debate very
complex debate but we have to rise to
the occasion and we have to be able to
deal with complexity we can't just deal
with simplicity as simplicity is not
there the planetary system is complex
yeah and we have to grapple with the
complexity here and designed policies
which actually takes textin account the
complex interdependent st. a
connectivity of issues yeah but you were
asking you also the question was are
there any process there are there an
example examples of supranational
successful processes in debrecen and i
would i'd point to the european union
the basic reason for the european union
to come to be great it was was to to
neutralize the rivalry between Germany
France and Britain that had gone on for
four hands and hands handful of years
and and
to a very creative statesman germany and
robert schumann who were brother bay by
the way exercise during the war here and
were part of the debate here how to
organize the peace bretton woods and
United Nations and so forth now they
were very skillful to understanding that
you have to start this project in the
economy so they align the interests of
Germany and France in the production of
steel so that's what's the origin the
Coal and Steel union between Germany and
and and France and out of that crew
hummin market the common market and at
the European Parliament European
Commission and so forth and which is
very important in all our lives and and
and also i think the ozone depletion
crisis that the Montreal Protocol
Montreal Protocol I think perhaps
another example where yeah that's also a
very good but I'm afraid it's an
exception to the rule we have I tens of
thousands of women I've started five
hundred international agreements in the
field of our environment and there is
only a handful of them maximum I was a
five that habit accomplished to the
letter so the like like they like the
Cure the protocol you like the view it
has you know it's just specifically some
pepper here so exactly and Sweden is
situated by the Baltic Sea and the
Baltic Sea is one of the most polluted
sees in the world it's kind of dead did
I there's no there is yeah that'll to
thirty five percent of the Baltic is now
that and we are nine nations bordering
to the Baltic and we have had a
Christmas of agreements and agreements
and and the efficiency of these
agreements are like 20 25 percent it's
very sad story which means that we have
to we have to assume the leadership and
not say them I said we have to assume
the leadership that expands our our
capacity for solidarity and in order to
do things income of the things that we
need to do do in common to solve problem
so so in that sense yes sovereignty must
cede to the problem but in the best
interest of myself yeah so there's a
direct link between self-interest and
smart policies yep now this this this
self-interest that has now become
predominant since the economic crisis of
2008 is that we have to protect our
market you have to protect our industry
and protect our jobs now in this climate
is a climate change going to take a
backseat it is it has a battery which is
which is appalling lack of of
responsibility if you are driving a car
towards the rib and you'll see there's a
rim you better break in time put the
brakes on in time and the science tells
us again and again again now with with
increasing precision that we are
approaching tipping points we losing the
chicken race so the time is is not on
our side but of course there's still
time
they came a book very interesting book a
few months ago written by by an American
scientist in at Oakland where he
described the world his name is Smith
professors method describes the world
2015 assuming that we will not be able
to stall a climate change and and that
describes the world here in the Americas
where the most habitable part would be
Canada and especially northern Canada
and as we ordered a note that the the
northern rim of Alaska Canada and Russia
is deeply affected by by the warming the
sowing of them of the of the ground and
so forth and in Europe who will see
major migration towards the north and we
also already see here in the United
States how how the Southwest is hit by
my draught yeah and wine fires and so
forth and the scientist tells me now
that we will have a record el nin you
next year so I say to myself at brace
yourself for another hardship period so
so the situation looks pretty dramatic
and yet we simply not oblivious of the
danger that is staring at of the face
now how does one go about finding some
records to this at at a non governmental
level yes that's where there's millions
and millions of young people and
businesses that are now driven by a new
worldview they understand that the world
is not steady state it's emergent they
understand that the world is complexity
and and
and that the world is also a
self-organizing they have a quite
different understanding of the role of
evolution and that they are proud of
evolution and I see in that context the
emergence of fantastic new technologies
materials information technologies and
so forth and I think that hope is is
very much we must be derived of us
understanding the word as complex as it
is and there are of course may I may
limits to conventional growth but I
don't think there are any limits to
human development as as as a collective
so I don't threat I don't I don't see
there's a threat that we become 9
billion or even 10 billion that will be
a source of New Energy new innovation
new creativity well on that optimistic
note Thank You Bookman for visiting us
and for your interview with us thank you
thank you